not all tornadoes are created equal and
some are much much scarier than others
the common tornadoes are the super thin
rope tornadoes or the conical-shaped
cone tornadoes or even the cylindrical
stove pipe tornadoes these are all scary
but not nearly as scary as the rarest
tornadoes known as wedge tornadoes this
is a tornado that's as wide as it is
tall sometimes over a mile or 1.6 km
wide and these tornadoes are
particularly dangerous because they hide
in plain sight they can be so enormous
that people don't even realize that
they're looking at a tornado they're
often mistaken for low hanging dark
clouds these devastating Twisters strike
seemingly out of nowhere catching people
unprepared some of the deadliest
tornadoes in US history have been wedges
many of which produced ef4 to EF5 damage
luckily only 2 to 3% of confirmed
tornadoes from 1950 to 2015 have been
wedged tornadoes